en un intento por rescatar de su
extinción a una pequeña población
aislada de serpientes en 1992 se
introdujeron algunas serpientes machos
de la misma especie provenientes de
poblaciones más grandes las serpientes
se reproducen sexualmente y hay
abundantes recursos en el medio ambiente
la siguiente figura muestra los
resultados de un estudio de la población
de serpientes tanto antes como después
de la introducción de los machos en el
estudio el número de serpientes
capturadas indica el tamaño de la
población vamos a ver los datos del
estudio en 1989 capturaron un montón de
serpientes estas son las serpientes
capturadas en total pero a una pequeña
fracción de ellas eran serpientes
jóvenes parece que alrededor de 5 de las
19 serpientes eran jóvenes y vemos que
la población total parece estar
disminuyendo dice que el número de
serpientes capturadas en total es un
indicativo de la población general que
está disminuyendo y luego introdujeron
los más
de otras poblaciones y se tarda un par
de años pero la población parece
aumentar de nuevo vamos a ver cuáles son
las preguntas
describe una característica de la
población original que pudo haber
provocado la disminución del tamaño de
la población entre 1989 y 1993 sólo
podemos teorizar no nos han dicho mucho
nos han dicho que es una población
pequeña y aislada pequeña población
aislada así que cuando hay una pequeña
población aislada algunas cosas pueden
suceder que es mucho menos probable que
sucedan si se tiene una población grande
que no está aislada voy a contestar aquí
es posible que haya una distribución
desigual de machos y hembras que no haya
suficientes
machos eso es menos probable que suceda
si se tiene una población muy grande
pero en una pequeña población aislada es
posible que no haya suficientes machos o
hembras si no hay suficientes machos no
va a haber suficiente reproducción
es posible que haya muy pocas serpientes
jóvenes en edad reproductiva que haya
muy pocas
serpientes
jóvenes
en edad
reproductiva
y puede haber un montón de razones por
las que esto pudo haber sucedido tal vez
ocurrió algún tipo de calamidad en 1988
donde muchas de las serpientes jóvenes
murieron tal vez algún tipo de
depredador por lo que todas las
serpientes que quedan son mayores y no
son tan viables en términos de
reproducción pero esa es una de las
posibilidades que hay
podría haber una mutación que está
apareciendo de manera desmesurada en esa
población que hace que sean menos
propensos a reproducirse una mutación
la
población que hace que sean menos
propensos a reproducirse para el examen
solo hay que describir una
característica y todas estas son
características posibles en el inciso b
dice propone una razón que expliqué como
la introducción de los machos externos
rescató a la población de serpientes de
su extinción si no había suficientes
machos la introducción de los machos
pudo
a ver
re equilibrado
la proporción
de machos
y hembras
pudo haber introducido diversidad
genética de manera que no haya una
mutación
pudo
haber introducido
diversidad
genética
una vez más se trata de una pequeña
población aislada eso nos puede llevar a
pensar que puede que no haya una gran
cantidad de diversidad genética hay las
serpientes machos introducidas podrían
haber sido más jóvenes
pudo
a ver
introducido
serpientes
más jóvenes
no nos indican la edad de los machos
externos pero estos son solo teorías
basadas en lo que nos dicen y esta es
una de las posibilidades y una vez más
sólo tienes que describir una razón por
la que podrías solo responder pudo haber
equilibrado la proporción de machos y
hembras y luego pasar al inciso c inciso
se describe como los datos apoyan la
declaración que indica que hay recursos
abundantes en el medio ambiente bueno si
vemos estos datos podríamos haber dicho
que tal vez una de las razones para el
inciso a es que los recursos no son
abundantes pero observa que cuando se
introducen machos externos la población
incrementa y sigue aumentando por lo que
el hecho de que la población siga
aumentando y alcancen números por encima
de donde estaba en 1989 es un muy buen
indicativo de que hay recursos en
abundancia no hay nada que esté
limitando este crecimiento una vez que
de alguna manera se soluciona el
problema mediante la introducción de
estos
externos por lo tanto podríamos decir
que
a partir de 1995
la población
aumentando
eso
no habría sucedido
si los recursos
no fueran
abundantes
y hemos terminado